all right today's topic since we did
part one on jubilee we lose second part
i'm gavrie i'm dennis he's my
ex-boyfriend
ex-girlfriend
[Music]
if anything she's gonna be asking a lot
of questions too because she won't shut
the [ __ ] up hey man the first video this
girl was talking for everybody okay
we're gonna hold it down
[Music]
so
i don't see anything
[Music]
and you notice also the difference
between this video and the other one the
other one
she was kind of like oh you're cute
you're so tall yeah you're too tall yeah
no no you have to talk yeah here's what
you're not good enough yeah you're fine
[Music]
hello how's it going i'm good how are
you
what's your name david dennis i'm
gabrielle dennis gabby gabriel
gabriel i remember that
yeah nice to meet you guys first
impressions on her
she was really pretty she was sorry
she was really pretty when i got closer
to her bit rough finally got one of them
angles on that ass and i was like yeah
not enough beautiful thinking
you're cool too when you start me uh to
the right i was like oh i like this guy
i mean obviously she's very pretty and i
like the crocs
no you don't like the crocs stop camping
listen okay i get you trying to get on a
good side but you don't have to lie
nobody likes a croc you're on tinder you
guys like left oh absolutely you're very
beautiful
also love the piercings oh thank you so
much my
mom yeah same i grew out the hair very
recently and she's like no i like it
it's super nice this is awkward right
the women were just talking to her and
the guys are just talking to her i feel
like this dude's invisible forever but
like i'm not gonna talk talk i'm not i'm
not gonna try to talk to the dude i
wouldn't talk to you hey man so uh how's
your ex
so talk to me about the [ __ ]
what is she like
she's right there why don't you just ask
her she like to get her ass eaten
because i know he's right there so
thanks dude
what's good my people i know that the
luck down has been hard on all of us
it's hard to see your friends it's hard
to see your family it's hard to see the
people that you love but on the first
lockdown i discovered this application
that is called pokerface uh was
pokerface it's a online social poker
game application it's not just that you
play poker but you can actually you see
the faces the whole camera the whole
microphone is on not necessarily you can
close that if you will but you can meet
people in converse with people while
you're playing poker i'm gonna go all in
on your ass man
that's really not the point of the game
the point of the game is to connect with
people and
it is free yes you heard me free 99 one
of the features that i really like is
that every day you get a free spin on a
wheel and that gets you duckets chips uh
fake mula that you can spend
on your poke game because you don't win
real money you don't lose real money so
right now you can go on the link that we
have and
you can have
three million chips for you to be able
to play with your people yeah it's free
we'll even post a link in a few days to
tell you uh when i'm gonna be online and
i'm gonna be able to play you're gonna
add me as a friend and we'll go and play
poker and i'm gonna take all your chips
because i don't play play okay guys just
stunting my left hand i gotta go eat
all right what are you like currently
looking for
uh a relationship would be nice
definitely someone who i can be like a
best friend with and be a homie with and
just do fun things bye guys
bye bye you would think that but these
young folks love this [ __ ]
true that is your generation these young
folks right you're right they'll be like
oh sexual elimination but we're just
vibing
we're not actually like dating
we're getting surviving money i'm just
diving
we're in a relationship
but we're not dating
yeah they'll say stuff like that yeah
so are you dating no no you're in a
relationship you're a couple yes but
you're not dating no no
the conflicting [ __ ]
[ __ ] that goes yeah yeah you know where
you're right it's my generation they
like that [ __ ] red flags in a
relationship relax
yeah i can't do toxicity uh not
communication which which is not a
problem
and believe it or not there is such a
thing
yeah some people think that because they
think something they have to say no
[ __ ] some of that [ __ ] can stay in your
[ __ ] head forever yes
the same way when i'm watching you and
you're watching a shitty ass show that
[ __ ] stays in my head i don't be here
like are you watching the best for that
no i'm like cool if she's always out
but
i don't you know i'm not i'm not really
like insecure just cheating
what's a red flag for you he said
cheating what's the reference that's not
a red flag that's what happened
that's after the red flag that's that's
what happened
that's what's a warning sign uh murder
pillaging the red a car crash no the
sign that the road was slippery was
arrest correct when did you realize that
hitler was a terrible person uh genocide
i think that was the
[Laughter]
dennis and gabriel good to meet you guys
meeting you cheers nice to meet you bro
yeah
thank you
how am i doing girl
dude i don't know this guy still doesn't
talk he doesn't i don't know anything
about him i know nothing about him i
don't even know he's been in two jubilee
videos had the most screen time possible
i don't know nothing about him but what
is he gonna say it's super awkward but i
get it
hey man she found something to say yeah
yes you might imagine if they go
one-on-one and this guy never talks
never talks
like so so yes or
what is she like
go cheating
uh sunny black guy
[Music]
and
the white dude
[Music]
hat
she likes the ethnic that's what we
gather
she likes the fascination or he likes
them from
from bollywood to niggerhood they like
that [ __ ] yeah
he's the west but i like to appreciate
when he chose he actually went for what
he's into when she chose she's like
sabotage do you want to be friends
sabotage yo such a difference
[Music]
this is more of like a conversation of
whether you guys are still like a like a
real thing or if you got
really friends you know you guys kind of
like agreed to this but that's the only
thing i really have you know i honestly
think it was like it was me definitely
me for the most part i like it was my
first relationship so i didn't know what
i was really looking for and the main
thing for me was like the balance of
time
i feel like because you're in school huh
yeah okay but when did you guys break up
like was it it's recent
we broke up one time like probably a
year ago and recently we broke up it's
like two months ago but then you guys
are like still cool in there yeah all
right that's good yeah you guys so cool
like you still see her i'm gonna i mean
two months i need you to get the [ __ ]
out
yeah i know it's weird two months yeah
and then you're picking it's a year i
would have given up but i guess i guess
it's the new generation i don't know bro
you know what this is this is just
messiness that's messy i think i don't
know how because you know what it just
takes a few drinks and they hook it up
again
that's how simple it is for people
two months yeah hold on hold on okay if
you about to date somebody and she just
broke up with somebody two months ago
but they still hang out and grab drinks
what you gonna think in your head
two months ago
they used to go out and grab drinks and
they had an on and off relationship
meaning they turned it off and turned it
back on and they grabbing drinks what
are you going to think sus
but i digress maybe it's just me
yeah i think
yeah
i think so yeah
[Music]
yeah good energy he came in confident
too like i feel like he would be
comfortable leading a conversation i'm
so used to leading conversations i kind
of like it when somebody is willing to
also do that so i can take a break for a
second
[Music]
he knew exactly what she wanted yeah
yeah he knew what he was doing which was
which is good yeah yeah
yeah
hello hi hi thank you yes of course
nice to finally meet you nice to meet
you without my ex-boyfriend yes
yeah
yeah it's like on his side it felt like
ugh yeah it's hard and it was me and
blah blah i'm letting go she was
ready yeah
good stuff but hey
we want to follow up on the video maybe
you guys felt differently than us let us
know what you guys think in the comments
below we want to hear from you
two months is a bit rough
two months it's weird